[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Anand iron I'm
today and I will be talking about coop
flow pipelines an exciting new set of
features that we've added to the popular
open source project coop flow you can
ask questions anytime on the platform
and we have Googlers on standby to
answer them so let's get started um
first some introductions real quick as I
mentioned my name is Anand a year and
I'm a product manager in the cloud AI
platform team within Google cloud the
cloud AI platform provides the set of
tools and services you need to build
custom machine learning applications
that entail building training and
deploying your own custom machine
learning models we're also very
fortunate to have andreas Rodriguez as
my co-presenter and he will be talking
about how Intel our very close partner
has leveraged coop flow pipelines to
build components for their open vino
toolkit so first let me present the
high-level agenda of the talk first I'll
present the motivations behind the
various tools and services that we're
building as part of the cloud ii i
platform and provide an overview of the
approach that we're taking next we will
do a deeper dive into the specific
problems that inspired the coop flow
pipelines initiative after that we'll
get into the meat of the presentation
which is where I'll give you a demo of
coops flow pipelines and also talk about
pertinent technical under the hood
technical details pertaining to coop
flow pipelines and after that I will
hand it over to andreas to talk about
how Intel has leveraged coop flow
pipelines to build components for their
open vino toolkit so first what was the
what's our motivation what are we trying
to solve as part of the cloud AI
platform the key problem that we're
trying to address is the fact that
building and deploying real-life ml
applications is harder and costlier than
it needs to be and that is because of
lack of tooling that covers the
end-to-end machine learning lifecycle
the end-to-end lifecycle for development
and deployment of custom machine
learning applications and that is the
key problem that we're trying to solve
now the the next couple of slides will
be a little bit of repetition for folks
that attended the previous webinar but
nevertheless I will cover this content
again real quick for those that may
watch this presentation later on YouTube
so when we talk to customers customers
mentioned three high-level themes or
rather when we spoke to customers there
were three high-level themes that
emerged as persistent problems that hold
customers back from building successful
machine learning applications the first
problem was that of deployment today's
infrastructure is brittle and
opinionated and the environments change
when you go from your laptop to the
cluster and also in today's world hybrid
is a reality the other big problem is
that of talent it's just really hard to
find machine learning experts and if
every machine learning application needs
a team of experts well that is going to
be a severe bottleneck for the
successful deployment of machine
learning then the last piece was
collaboration everyone is reinventing
the wheel and we implement implementing
components whereas the the ideal state
of the world is where different teams
collaborate and reuse assets that
they're building so this at a high level
are the these three problems at a high
level are the problems we want a taco
and the three pillars towards our
solution are coop flow reusable
pipelines and AI hub goop flow is a
popular open source project and coop
flow aims to simplify the end-to-end
machine learning lifecycle it provides a
set of services and libraries that are
seamlessly integrated that address the
needs of the various stages of a machine
learning application coop flow is a
collection of services that runs on the
kubernetes execution engine and we chose
kubernetes because kubernetes is
effectively the de facto for deploying
applications that leverage a cluster of
machines so by leveraging kubernetes
we're able to effectively provide a
hybrid solution because kubernetes is
the de facto platform on-premise as well
as on multiple clouds so by building
something that works on kubernetes were
able to provide the the
coop flow enables customers to move
their applications from on-premise
on-premise to the clouds and so forth
couple morass key aspects of coop flow
it is an open source library that
supports multiple machine learning
frameworks it is not limited to
tensorflow it supports I could learn
extry boost bite or chip and multiple
other frameworks and because it's open
source we work with the community to
assimilate newer frameworks that become
popular one more key thing to highlight
is the fact that while coop flow is open
source if you deploy coop flow on GCP
particularly on Google Google's
kubernetes engine gke we have built some
integrations that make it very seamless
to deploy coop flow and also for the the
most popular coop flow services you can
leverage fully managed equivalence on
Google cloud so you don't always have to
manage your infrastructure the other
aspect is reusable pipelines and and
over here the Lego analogy is very apt
we want to get to a world where
components and pipelines built by others
can seamlessly be we use we don't want
people to reinvent the wheel all the
time and this is particularly important
because in today's world every machine
learning application is considered to be
a bespoke application so whenever
someone is building a custom machine
learning application the first thing
they need is a data scientist or machine
learning engineer that is focused on
that application and we'll build a
bespoke solution but that is not always
the case
often what you need to do is actually
look at other successful applications
and reuse the stuff they've built and
tweak the components that you need to
tweak and that is what we want to enable
then the third aspect is the AI hub the
AI hub you can think of it as a one-stop
shop or a one-stop catalog for machine
learning content and I use the word
content because we will have multiple
different types of assets we will
clearly have pipelines built with coop
flow pipelines infrastructure we will
also have usable components that you can
leverage as a part of coop flow
pipelines but we will also have other
assets like pre trained models or
embeddings or even just notebooks where
a particular model is being trained so
long story short AI hub becomes
one-stop shop to find assets that you
can either reuse or use as inspiration
to build your own custom applications
alright so with that now let's do a
deeper dive into these specific problems
that inspired the coop flow pipelines
project
so the key premise here is the fact that
in addition to the actual machine
learning right and what I mean by the
actual ml we're talking about the code
that trains the model or does influence
with the model in addition to that there
are multiple other phases that you
actually have to implement and manage
for a successful end-to-end machine
learning application there's data
integration data collection feature
engineering data validation model
deployment and then tooling to capture
metrics and orchestrate all these pieces
together and that can often get
non-trivial and that is a core problem
that we want to solve
let me also present a few customer
quotes that will make things more
tangible one customer that we spoke to
said that they don't really have an ml
workflow today what they've basically
done is taken workflows that they've
used for general software development
and applied that in the machine learning
context but that lacks the things that
ml needs and that is one problem you
want to solve the other problem is we
spoke to customers where they don't
retrain their models on a frequent basis
despite the fact that model freshness
was actually important for their
business and part of the reason they
don't retrain models as often is because
the retraining process was very manual
but we wanted to solve that problem and
make it very easy for customers to set
up constant or retraining pipelines that
can be scheduled to run on a periodic
basis so that they can get newer updated
models more easily a third customer that
we spoke to basically said ml
experimentation is like the Wild West
today everyone is using ad hoc tools
there is no standardization it's very
hard to go back and understand what led
to the production of a particular model
it's hard to know what techniques have
been tried what experiments have been
run and so on and so forth and we want
to solve that we want to make it easy
for you to have one place where you can
track all the experiments that were done
so with that let me dive into
the demo section where we will cover
pertinent aspects of the qu flow
pipelines project before we dive in I
want to talk about the the three feature
buckets into which the capabilities of
coop flow pipelines can be classified
the three buckets are machine learning
workflow orchestration rapid reliable
experimentation and sharing reuse and
composability so the qu flow pipelines
project at a very high level is solving
problems that fall under these three
buckets so first let me talk about ML
workflow orchestration because we've
been talking about multi-step machine
learning pipelines let me make things
more concrete by first presenting a
visual depiction of a pipeline that has
been executed on the coop flow pipelines
framework so this is the coop flow
pipelines console depicting an actual
pipeline that was executed now in this
particular case this pipeline starts
with a validation step where incoming
data is analyzed to make sure that there
are no data quality issues after that
there is a pre-processing step followed
by a training step and then the model
that's produced in the training step in
one scenario is used for predict doing
prediction on offline data in another
scenario the same model is being
deployed to a serving end point and then
there's a third process where the model
is being used to do deeper analysis on
the validation data set now this is just
an illustrative pipeline and you can
build multiple different configurations
of pipelines with this framework a few
key things to highlight here is our in
addition to the visual depiction of the
stages of the pipeline which makes it
very easy for you to come in and
understand what that pipeline is doing
in addition to this visual depiction you
actually get a whole set of rich
information required to understand at
you know sufficient detail what was
happening when this pipeline was
executed so you can see all the
configuration parameters and all the
input parameters that were provided to
the pipeline for each step of the
pipeline you can drill deep and select a
particular step and then see the inputs
and outputs of that individual step so
the N
foods that were provided what were the
outputs that were produced you can also
look at logs that were produced so that
you can you know debug things when they
fail or get a deeper understanding of
what happened when that step was run
what is particularly compelling is
certain steps will produce interesting
data that can be visualized so for
example if you're doing analysis and in
this particular case the analysis step
was implemented using the tensor flow
model analysis component that's part of
the tf-x library it produces a rich set
of artifacts that can be visualized with
this slice-and-dice UI and the the
visualization of the metrics is embedded
right here in the console so for the
metrics that are produced you can
visualize them right here so in this
particular case you can do slicing and
dicing off the the metrics produced by
that model let's take another example if
I go to the prediction step I can
visualize the output which is tabular
output where each offline data set and
the corresponding score assigned to it
can be visualized and if I go to the
training step for example I can by the
click of a button open the tensor board
instance where I can now get a deeper
understanding of what happened when that
model was trained so long story short a
lot of rich visual information is
readily available at your fingertips so
that you can understand what happened
when a pipeline was run so let me go
back and cover some pertinent details
about how what constitutes a pipeline
and exactly what are the the pieces that
define a coupe flow pipeline in its
simplest form a coupe flow pipeline is a
set of containerized machine learning
tasks the reason we chose containers is
because containers are the industry
standard for portability repeatability
and encapsulation and and of course we
want you to go from prototyping to
production as quickly as possible and
thus container izing your steps enables
that we also wanted repeatability and
reliability and again containers are the
industry standard solution for that and
that's why we did not want to reinvent
that and we
leverage containers but that being said
even though a single task each step of
the pipeline is a containerized task
that doesn't mean it has to run on a
single node a given task can be can can
run in distributed fashion it can be a
model that's trained in distributed
fashion it can be an apache spark step
which is doing distributed data
processing or an Apache beam step that's
doing distributed data processing the
key thing of one highlight is even
though a given step is encapsulated as a
container when it's actually deployed on
the kubernetes cluster it can run on
multiple worker nodes so it can run in
distributed fashion another thing worth
highlighting is the different steps of
the pipeline can use different hardware
so you can have the training step which
needs GPUs and then the the
pre-processing steps probably just need
a high memory CPU machine a high memory
machine for for distributed processing
but the key thing is different steps the
pipeline can leverage different forms of
hardware and it's very easy for you to
specify what hardware is acquired a
third thing I want to highlight is the
fact that even though a step of the
pipeline is executed as a container
these containerized steps can easily
invoke cloud native services that are
running elsewhere so for example you can
have a containerized step that is
calling cloud machine learning api's or
you can have a containerized step that
is calling out to other fully managed
services like bigquery or cloud machine
learning engine or dataflow so that's a
core part of what a coop flow pipeline
is it's a set of machine containers that
encapsulate machine learning tasks the
other part of it is specifying the
higher level workflow specifying the
sequence in which these tasks need to be
run and and to do that we provide a very
intuitive Python SDK that I'll demo in
in a few seconds then the third piece
that constitutes a pipeline or the set
of parameters that the user has to pass
in so and when we say a coop flow
pipeline that essentially constitutes
the containers for the individual steps
the higher-level workflow definition and
the parameters that the user has to pass
in so with that let's go back and take a
look at how a coupe flow pipeline is
authored
so as I mentioned we provided a very
intuitive Python SDK and time and again
when we spoke to our customers everyone
said Python is that lingua franca so
essentially we decided to provide a very
pythonic SDK that will feel intuitive to
our audience and this Python SDK can for
example be invoked from an IDE or even
from a notebook and because authoring
machine learning components from
notebooks is as popular these days I'll
actually demo usage of the the coop flow
pipelines SDK from a notebook so when it
comes to authoring a pipeline there are
two distinct raises one is defining the
higher-level workflow and then the other
is defining the individual components
and first let me start with the
higher-level workflow and what I mean by
the high-level workflow is the
definition of the sequence in which
these steps need to be executed so to
define the work flow essentially
authoring the workflow is as intuitive
as authoring a Python function you
essentially define a Python function
that encapsulates your workflow and then
you annotate that with a function
decorator that essentially signifies
that this is a cool flow pipeline
definition for your function you will
provide arguments which are essentially
the inputs that an end user needs to
provide while running the pipeline and
you can even annotate these arguments
with one second let me find the cursor I
seem to have lost the cursor oh there we
go so the arguments can be annotated so
that you can specify a name for each
argument and also specify a default
value and we'll come back to why that is
very useful and significant so long
story short you define a Python function
you specify arguments these are the
inputs to the function and then you
start specifying the different steps of
the pipeline and how they're hooked
together each step of the pipeline is
invoked like a Python function now at
this point you're wondering wait a
minute each step of the pipeline is a
containerized step how did it become a
Python function just hold on to that
thought and I'll answer that question in
a few minutes but for now assume that
each step of the pipeline is
encapsulated as a Python function so to
specify the workflow it's as easy as
calling the corresponding function
providing the inputs that that function
require
and then the sequence in which the
different steps need to be executed is
specified by connecting the output of
one function and providing that as the
input to a downstream function so in
this particular case the first function
of the first step of the pipeline
produces some output which is pre
processed output and then the
pre-processed output is provided as
input to the training step and that's
how you specify the sequence in which
the steps need to be run so that was
specifying the workflow orchestration
well actually and before we move on I
should mention that after you've defined
this function we give you simple the SDK
gives you simple operations where you
can compile this higher-level workflow
definition into a tar.gz file that can
be uploaded to the pipeline's back-end
or you can also just use our client API
to submit the pipeline to the the qu
flow pipelines back-end and once it's
uploaded to the pipeline system any user
can come in pick that pipeline and
execute it naturally let me depict that
over here so let's say you go in you
want to create a new run so you open
this create a new run by specifying a
pipeline and then as soon as you specify
a pipeline you give it a name and then
you actually have this form that is
automatically populated which specifies
the inputs that you need to provide to
this pipeline I mean this is where the
annotations to the function arguments
were important so the annotations
specify the the names of each input and
the annotations also specify the default
values for these inputs so all you had
to do was author that pipeline specify
the pipeline as a function specify your
function arguments and annotate them and
that automatically becomes this easy to
consume form that someone can use when
they want to execute the pipeline and
this is important because often the
author of the pipeline is not going to
be the one that executes the pipeline in
many cases the author is going to
execute the pipeline but we want to get
to a world where the author of the
pipeline can give the pipe give it a
pre-built pipeline the other is to go
and execute so I can
come in not no more too many details
about how a particular pipeline works
under the hood but I can come in I can
see what inputs are required type them
into this form and execute the pipeline
it's as easy as that all right going
back to the notebook here now let's talk
about how the different steps of the
pipeline are specified well as I
mentioned each step of the pipeline is a
containerized step so in its most basic
and most flexible form all you have to
do is once you have your container so
let's take this example here where I've
built a container that encapsulates one
step of my pipeline I can take this
container and I basically wrap it with a
Python function where I invoke this
operation called the container op so
this container op which is part of the
coop flow pipelines
SDK it takes as input the container that
encapsulates the step and also it takes
as input the various parameters that
need to be passed in by the end user and
this container op takes care of invoking
that container and passing it the
corresponding parameters now often each
container has its own default entry
point and often by default that's the
entry point that's executed but
sometimes containers can have multiple
different entry points and you can
override the entry point that needs to
be invoked by using a command called the
it's called command you can specify that
inside the container op and then specify
which entry point has to be used for a
container so long story short once you
have encapsulated your pipeline as a
container all you have to do is wrap it
with this container up and we make it
and and this produces essentially a
Python function version of this
operation that you can then use when
you're defining your workflow now at
this point you're wondering hey wait a
minute does that mean every step that I
author every step of the pipeline needs
to be built as a container that is not
the case I actually wanted to start with
the most flexible method of defining
pipeline steps because anything that can
be put in a container is fair game it
can be C++ code are scripts and
what-have-you
but often you will not as an end-user
have to build the containers yourself
you can actually go in
and just author steps of a pipeline has
a simple Python function and then after
you've authored the function annotate
that function with specific function
decorators that help encapsulate that
function as a step of the pipeline and
when you do so when when you specify the
function decorators all you have to do
is specify a base image a base docker
image that is used to package that step
of the pipeline often you can get base
docker images by going to docker hub for
example if you're training a tensorflow
pipeline the tensorflow community
produces provides a bunch of pre-built
docker containers that are available on
docker hub with various versions of
tensorflow and common utilities and you
can just simply reuse those containers
or if you're working in a large
organization you may have your internal
github
oh sorry docker hub but in many cases a
pre-built container may not have the the
various libraries that you specifically
need and again we we have you covered
over there so all you have to do is use
this notebook magic that we have
provided where you specify the base
container that you want to use so in
this particular case I'm going to use a
tensorflow base container and then after
that simply pip install the other
dependencies that you need and of course
if you're you know folks that use Python
are very comfortable with pip install so
you don't need to know the details of
docker docker ization all you have to do
is use this notebook magic specify a
base container and then specify the
other dependencies that need to be
packaged into that base container and we
automatically produce a container that
you can use as step of the pipeline and
it'll have your custom dependencies so
long story short you don't have to be an
expert to author each individual state
an expert in docker author each
individual step of the pipeline we give
you the utilities that you need to
simplify the authoring of the various
steps alright so that was authoring of
machine learning pipelines now let's go
back and look at the other key value
proposition of coop for pipelines which
is rapid reliable experimentation and
this is important because machine
learning particularly applied machine
learning when you
machine learning applications it's all
about trying many different techniques
the more techniques you can try higher
your likelihood of success and that is
what we want to enable we wanted we want
to make it very easy for you to simply
author an initial pipeline clone that
pipeline edit it to try some variant of
that pipeline and then submit it and
keep doing this loop very quickly so you
can try multiple different variants and
of course for each pipeline that you've
submitted you can view those pipelines
in the coop flow pipelines console so
you could have thousands of executions
you can go in and you can see rich
information about each execution what is
particularly compelling is as I
mentioned we want to make it easy for
you to to try variants of your pipeline
by simply cloning it editing it and
submitting it and let me actually demo
that so take an existing pipeline hit
the clone button and that opens up this
web form that you can now tweak you can
update the parameters that go in and
then you can submit that cloned variant
of the pipeline and you can do this ad
nauseam and pretty soon we will actually
add capabilities where you can clone a
pipeline see a version of the code tweak
the code and submit so long story short
try multiple different variants to see
what works best
now for each variant of your pipeline
you can actually see rich metrics
produced by that pipeline quickly so you
can identify the the ones that worked
well and then you can select say a
subset of the pipeline's
let's just say you want to do some
comparisons let me go in here because
often when you've launched multiple
variants of a pipeline you want to go in
and compare them to see what was
different about them so I can select a
subset of pipelines and hit the compare
runs button and I get this rich UI where
I get rich information the metrics
config parameters and so forth of those
executions side-by-side so I can easily
analyze them and figure out what was
different about each execution and what
is particularly compelling and I find
that very this one this feature very
interesting if you've done training
where you produce metrics that can be
visualized by tensor board for the
various experiments that you selected
with one click you can open a tensor
board instance where all the
metrics from those different experiments
are plotted in the same set of plot so
you can do Grich analysis of your
experiments and then the last piece is
reusability reusability of pipelines and
components so let me quickly depict that
so let's just say you've authored a
multi-step pipeline in this particular
case you have a six step pipeline not
every step of the pipeline has to be
authored by you in many cases you will
find existing components from say the AI
hub that you can reuse as a part of your
pipeline another example is where you
might have an existing pipeline you just
want to swap one step of the pipeline
with a different step so let's just say
you have a pipeline that uses
scikit-learn to do some training and
then you soon realize that in the AI hub
there is a tensor flow based
implementation that might just work
great for your use case well fantastic
just simply swap the training component
of a pipeline and now you have a new
variant that you can try so that's how
coop flow pipelines helps you go from
prototype into production real quick and
with that I'd like to introduce andreas
Rodriguez to talk about how you can use
open vino to get the most out of your
coop flow pipelines
you
six and four introducing the key flow of
pythons before I proceed I encourage you
to continue typing your questions and
there are Google and Intel engineers
answering them Intel and Google are
partnering to enhance the conferral
pipelines as a first step Intel added
the open unit toolkit as containers to a
cue flow pipe limbs to start I want to
motivate the reason for the opener
toolkit then give a brief overview of up
Amina and then share how open we know
can be used with the cue flow pipelines
inter provide a diversity of hardware
that can be used for artificial
intelligence each one has different
strengths such as better throughput
better latency or better power or better
memory or better cause or better
generality depending on the specific
application in toast a a hardware
products includes the various types of
CPUs for both data center and client
GPUs vp use or visual processing units
FPGAs and enemies or neural network
processor accelerators given the
hardware diversity Intel develop a
unified API and software toolkit that
can be used for inference across all the
various hardware products this software
tool known is known as open vino which
stands for open visual inference and
neural Nets optimization open window has
three main components the deep learning
deployment toolkit or dl/dt and open CV
and media SDK used for traditional
vision and video processing and a
collection of pre-trained models and
tutorials a high-level open window
provides a unified programming model
across various hardware is optimized for
performance and memory footprint is
extendable for custom workloads provides
broad operating systems of
it's self-contained for a simple
out-of-the-box experience and is open
source for the community to enhance and
contribute the main component that we
will focus in this presentation is dl/dt
in touch deep learning deployment
toolkit it offers a model optimizer and
an Infernus engine for optimal inference
across various intel's hardware products
the deep learning deployment toolkit or
dl/dt is easy to use and provides high
performance across
into's hardware products before using
the ODT you first need to train a model
you can train a model using one of the
many popular tip learning frameworks on
your hardware of choice your training on
Intel Xeon processors use the Intel MKL
DNA library to accelerate your training
dl/dt has two steps first dl/dt provides
an optimized intermediate representation
or ir over the models graph this
includes optimizations such as layer
fusions organization second this IR is
then consumed by the inference engine
optimized across various hardware
products on the left in this slide you
can see a list of currently supported
layers Intel continues to expand this
list if a list sorry if a given layer is
not currently supported documentation is
provided detailing how user can add new
primitives or layers or how to further
optimize existing layers a feature of
the ldt is heterogeneous execution or
the ability to execute a model across
various hardware products in this
example there is a primitive of a model
not supported or optimized for FPGA that
is scheduled to execute on the CPU
another feature is asynchronous
execution to hide their transfers that
is as one infinite cycles executed
open Vino fetches the data for the next
inference cycle once you have your
optimized intermediate representation
you
seen the dl/dt inference engine is as
simple as this five layers of core nor
that in the third line of code that's
highlighted the user can select from
multiple hardware products this enables
the user to quickly compare performance
across various hardware products to
determine which one may be the most
suitable for a particular model into has
been working with several customers to
enable them to do AI on Intel's hardware
products here are a few examples of
customers we work with and their
testimonials ga for example observed a
14 times performance improvement using
the open window toolkit for their tasks
of inference across x-ray imagery
several other customers report up to two
orders of magnitude performance gains on
Intel Xeon processors using interest
optimizations internal Google partnering
to bring the performance and ease of use
of open vino to a masses by adding dl/dt
containers to a cube flow problems let's
review the key flow pipeline via a
hypothetical example suppose your data
scientists at American AI company
examining x-rays to detect cancerous
cells there are various containers to
facilitate your work the data ingestion
data transformation and data validation
containers facilitate reading data
transforming the data to the expected
format and validating that the x-ray
data is usable and properly labeled this
data is passed with training to the
trainer container the output in this
hypothetical example is a trained cancer
detection model that is passed to the
model validation container to ensure the
model is ready for deployment observing
the train model is then used for serving
by your medical company to examine
patients
x-rays the dl/dt more optimizer takes
the train model and passes it to the
kettle sorry and get an optimized
intermediate representation which guess
which gets passed to a do DT inference
engine for high performance across the
various Hardware a backends note that
nor audit
containers are needed to use the dl/dt
containers the dl/dt model optimizer can
use an existing train model we have only
provided a high-level overview we invite
you to try the Q flow pipelines with
open window containers in the links
provider we offer two simple examples
for each of the dl/dt containers to help
you get started and you can learn more
about the benefits of open vena using
the link at the bottom see to now for
live Q&A we will be back in less than a
minute
you
looks like we have a question from the
audience what are the advantages of the
open V no toolkit over other serving
solutions and risk all yours
thanks Anand open windows optimized by
in town for optimal performance across
in toast our back ends however we're
working to extend the benefits to other
influence engines for example were
working to more tightly a couple some of
the benefits of open window with literal
serving so that digital serving can also
have the same or very similar
performance gains and ease of use that
we can get with open vino for intel's
hardware alright stay tuned now for the
next session
CET v introducing cloud TPU pod 11.5
petaflop supercomputer for deep learning
thank you
[Music]